Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Her Majesty is a pretty nice girl, but she doesn't have a lot to say her majesty's a pretty nice girl but she changes from day to day i want to tell her that i love her a lot but i gotta get a belly full of wine her majesty's a pretty nice girl someday i'm gonna make her mine oh yeah someday i'm gonna make her mine bum bum that dominic uh as of course you'll know as a top historian of the 60s was the beatles her majesty was it was it was i felt that you didn't really i you only approached that half-heartedly tom by your standards so we we meet in the wake
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。女王陛下是个挺好的姑娘，虽然她没多少话要讲，女王陛下是个挺好的姑娘，但她天天都在变样，我想告诉她我非常爱她，但我得先灌一肚子的酒，女王陛下是个挺好的姑娘，总有一天我要让她成为我的，哦耶，总有一天我要让她成为我的，砰砰，那个多米尼克，呃，正如你当然知道的，作为六十年代的顶级历史学家，那就是披头士乐队，女王陛下，那是，那是，我觉得你其实并没有，多米尼克，你只是半心半意地唱了那首，按照你的标准，所以我们在你的绝对一流的——
of your absolutely stellar hercule parow and by those very high standards I felt you did live a Padleian accent unless that was your live a Padleian accent no it wasn't no no well I wasn't singing it as Paul McCartney I was singing it as a tribute to the musical tradition that the Beatles embodied and indeed as a tribute to her majesty there were levels of new accent there that I didn't appreciate well that's why I'm here to tease them out for you, Dominic. Yeah, thank you. That's very kind. And talking of teasing out, the reason that I picked on that was partly because I know the lyrics, so that was easy. But also because, actually, I think there's quite a lot of meaning in there that we could pick out.
——赫ercule parow（此处疑为口误，帕罗）之后相聚，以那样极高的标准，我觉得你确实展现了帕多利亚口音，除非那是你的帕多利亚口音，不，不是的，不，不，好吧，我唱它不是在模仿保罗·麦卡特尼，我是把它作为对披头士乐队所体现的音乐传统的致敬，当然也是对女王陛下的致敬，那里有些新的口音级别是我所没有欣赏到的，好吧，这就是为什么我在这里为你把它们挑出来，多米尼克。是的，谢谢。这太好了。说到挑出来，我挑中这个的部分原因是因为我知道歌词，所以那很简单。但也是因为，实际上，我认为里面有很多我们可以挑出来的深意。
So we've got the Platinum Jubilee of the Queen coming up. So there'll be lots of people, Cap preeminent among them who will be wanting to tell the queen that they love her a lot and there'll be lots of people getting a metaphorical belly full of wine yes we've got a holiday haven't we and they're all these kind of these cakes and things that the platinum jubilee cake and stuff that apparently very complicated to make now i thought it was i thought it was very easy with just that you just add lemon or something no no i've read i read an article or Oh, it was in The Guardian, I think. It's probably wrong, then, isn't it?
所以我们迎来了女王的白金禧年。因此会有很多人，其中杰出代表会想要告诉女王他们非常爱她，而且会有很多人喝得酩酊大醉，是的，我们有个假期，对吧，还有所有这些蛋糕之类的东西，白金禧年蛋糕之类的，据说现在做起来非常复杂，现在我以为，我以为这很简单，只要加点柠檬什么的就行，不，不，我读过，我读过一篇文章，或者，是在《卫报》上看到的，我想。那可能就错了，对吧？
Anyway, yes. We're just wittering. So for people who don't, for outsiders, we should say it's the Queen's Platinum Jubilee. It's a moment of seismic significance for every right-thinking Briton, isn't it, Tom? Yes. And we thought we'd do a Jubileeilee a special jubilee podcast and tom we've got a guest haven't we a very exciting guest we do indeed and so we have francis christie who is the deputy chairman of sotheby's who are kindly sponsoring um this episode and francis i
无论如何，是的。我们只是在闲聊。所以对于那些不了解的人，对于局外人，我们应该说这是女王的白金禧年。对于每个有理智的英国人来说，这是一个具有震撼意义的时刻，不是吗，汤姆？是的。我们觉得我们可以做一期禧年，一个特别的禧年播客，汤姆，我们有一位嘉宾，对吧，一位非常令人兴奋的嘉宾，我们确实有，所以我们请来了弗朗西斯·克里斯蒂，苏富比拍卖行的副主席，他们好心地赞助了，嗯，这一期节目，弗朗西斯，
mean with your surname being christie you must be bored of people making jokes about that as i am of people making jokes about spider-man it's's the deputy chairman of Christie's called Francis Sotheby. That would also be cool. It's not quite as cool as Christie at Sotheby's, I think, obviously, because I am Christie at Sotheby's. Of course. Your area of specialisation is modern British Irish art, a well-known face on the Antiques Roadshow. But specifically, you're here because you have curated a special kind of festival, a Platinum Jubilee Festival at Sotheby's, which will be going on from, when is it? End of May through to June? End of May to the middle of June.
我是说，你的姓氏是克里斯蒂，你一定对别人开这种玩笑感到厌烦了，就像我对别人开蜘蛛侠的玩笑一样，克里斯蒂拍卖行的副主席叫弗朗西斯·苏富比。那也很酷。不过显然没有克里斯蒂在苏富比那么酷，因为我就是苏富比的克里斯蒂。当然。你的专长领域是现代英国和爱尔兰艺术，是《古董巡回秀》里一张熟知的面孔。但具体来说，你来到这里是因为你在苏富比策划了一种特殊的艺术节，一个白金禧年艺术节，将从，是什么时候开始？从五月底一直持续到六月？从五月底到六月中旬。
And we'll have stuff going on right to the end of June. And that's going on at New Bond Street? At New Bond Street, right in the middle, 34 to 35. Free and open to the public. And you've got celebrities coming in to give talks. You've got Andrew Roberts, is that right and we've got loads of things going on we've got talks for kids from michael mappugo up to a battle of the bears i've got dancing bears from the balkans paddington versus winnie the pooh oh oh so not gladiatorial
而且我们的活动将一直持续到六月底。活动是在新邦街举办吗？在新邦街，就在正中心，34号到35号。免费向公众开放。你们还请了名人来做讲座。有安德鲁·罗伯茨，是这样的吗，我们有各种各样的活动，我们有面向儿童的讲座，从迈克尔·莫波格，一直到“熊之战”，我有来自巴尔干地区的跳舞的熊，帕丁顿熊对决小熊维尼，哦，哦，所以不是角斗式的，
although i mean you could put you could put in some um i'm sure you could put in some um some ideas to make it gladiatorial um but battle of the bears we're very excited about we've got a battle of the queens as well um victoria versus queens with the first you know we had we had the world cup of kings and queens yeah um and uh actually i think elizabeth second she got to the semi-finals didn't she did she who was she against she was i think she was against athelstan and who so who was the winner athelstan we thought it would be elizabeth first you didn't you haven't got an athelstan theme at your exhibition sadly not but i can make a suggestion it's not too late well let's see if
虽然，我的意思是你可以放进一些，我确信你可以放进一些，一些想法让它具有角斗士的风格，嗯，但对于“熊之战”，我们感到非常兴奋，我们还有“女王之战”，嗯，维克托娅女王对阵第一位伊丽莎白女王，你知道的，我们曾举办过国王和女王世界杯，嗯，而且，实际上我认为伊丽莎白二世她进入了半决赛，不是吗？是吗？她当时的对手是谁？我想她的对手是阿塞尔斯坦，那么谁是赢家？阿塞尔斯坦。我们原本以为会是伊丽莎白一世。你们的展览里没有阿塞尔斯坦的主题吗？很遗憾没有，但我可以提个建议，现在还不算太晚。好吧，让我们看看
we can work it in today um because um's podcast, we're structuring it around six items that you have chosen from the exhibition that you're staging, each one of which highlights a distinctive aspect, not just of the Elizabethan age, but of Elizabeth II herself and our relationship to her. So what is the first that you have chosen so let's go for the most obvious one that hopefully everyone would recognize anyway um and that's the andy warhol portrait of queen elizabeth ii well obviously we're on a podcast so people can't see the image should i describe it it's it's um as a lot of people know andy warhol loved loved popular images so he would take photographs of celebrities and people and he once said um i want to be as famous as the queen of england so it was apt then when he made her one of his subjects annoying all the scots and welsh and yeah and more than irish don't forget them yeah um so he took one of the formal portraits from the 77th Silver Jubilee by someone called Peter Grudgen.
我们今天能不能把它融合进来，嗯，因为，嗯，的播客，我们围绕你从正在举办的展览中挑选的六件展品来构建，每一件展品都突出了一个独特的方面，不仅是伊丽莎白时代，还有伊丽莎白二世本人以及我们与她的关系。那么你选择的第一件展品是什么？让我们选最明显的那一件，希望无论如何每个人都能认出来，嗯，那就是安迪·沃霍尔创作的伊丽莎白二世女王肖像。很显然我们是在录播客，所以大家看不到图像，我应该描述一下吗？它，嗯，正如很多人所知，安迪·沃霍尔热爱大众图像，所以他会给名人拍照，他曾经说过，嗯，我希望能和英国女王一样出名，所以当他把她作为创作对象时就很贴切了，这惹恼了所有的苏格兰人、威尔士人以及，是的，还有爱尔兰人，别忘了他们，是的，嗯，所以他采用了77年银禧年时的官方肖像之一，由一个叫彼得·格鲁金的人拍摄。
And he styled that photo, I guess, with colour and his own with his own celebrity treatment. And I guess that in itself could have been quite controversial at the time because, you know, perhaps the Queen is above celebrity treatment. So I'm kind of looking at the moment she's got kind of joker style she looks like a kind of gotham city villain and with with purple face yes purple skin rather and deep blue hair but i don't think the queen is above celebrity and i don't think she ever was so some people might see this as the collision of celebrity with something sacred almost dare i say sacral tom but uh but but i would say the queen uh when she born 1926 um so she's born into a world where the celebrity culture already exists through gossip magazines
我想他用色彩和自己标志性的名人处理手法来设计了这张照片。我想这本身在当时可能会颇具争议，因为，你知道的，也许女王超越了名人处理的范畴。所以我现在看到的是，她有一种小丑风格的妆容，她看起来像个哥谭市的恶棍，有着紫色的脸，是的，紫色皮肤，还有深蓝色的头发，但我不认为女王超越了名人，我也不认为她曾经是那样，所以有些人可能会认为这是名流文化与某种神圣事物的碰撞，甚至我敢说是神圣的，汤姆，但，但，但我想说，女王，嗯，她生于1926年，所以她出生在一个八卦杂志中已经存在名人文化的世界上，
and um sort of picture post type things i mean i know that's his heyday comes a little bit later, but that the Royal, that she was always a celebrity even when she was a little girl and that Warhol's not doing anything necessarily new with this, I would say. I mean, she's arguably, and I know we don't think of her as a celebrity because we think of film stars and rock stars as celebrities,
以及，嗯，某种画报类型的杂志，我的意思是，我知道它的全盛时期来得稍晚一些，但皇室，她一直是个名人，即使在她还是个小女孩的时候，而沃霍尔这样做并不一定是在进行什么创新，我想说。我的意思是，可以说，而且我知道我们并不认为她是一个名人，因为我们把电影明星和摇滚明星视为名人，
but you could argue she's the single most recognisable the 20th century couldn't you i think i think she is and i think that's sort of what's so clever about andy warhol portraying her like this is that like the brits would never portray her like this but it takes a kind of american cool new yorker to show the queen in the same way that he showed marilyn monroe and i think that that sort of shows what the world thought of her as well, that she was totally deserving of this amazing accolade in a way to be treated as the ultimate celebrity. And I guess we wanted to choose this picture because she's the only queen that's really been in technicolor, if you like. She's the first monarch to have their coronation filmed the other
但你可以争辩说，她是20世纪辨识度最高的人，难道不是吗？我想，我想是的，而且我认为这正是安迪·沃霍尔这样描绘她的精妙之处，因为英国人绝不会这样描绘她，但需要一个有点酷的纽约美国人，以展示玛丽莲·梦露的相同方式来展示女王，我认为这某种程度上也表明了世界对她的看法，那就是她完全配得上获得这种惊人的赞誉，被当作终极名人来对待。我想我们之所以选择这张照片，是因为她是唯一一位真正生活在彩色电影时代的女王，如果你愿意这么说的话。她是第一位将加冕典礼被拍成电影的君主。
thing about this image so yeah it's your kind of classic wall but it also is it not very similar to a kind of is it it's an icon i mean it's literally an icon as in a kind of orthodox you know the sort of icons that you would see in russian or greek or ukrainian churches or something the sort of the framing of it is very similar to an icon and the queen that sort of thing that in eastern orthodoxy they had with icons which is they were very kind of unearthly and they were not deliberately not naturalistic and they didn't show emotion and all that sort of thing i mean that kind of seems right for the queen doesn't it because the whole she's always been as much symbol as kind of a flesh and blood personality.
关于这幅图像的另一件事，是的，这是你那种经典的沃霍尔风格，但它难道不非常类似于某种，是吗？它是一个圣像，我的意思是，字面意思上的圣像，就像那种东正教的，你知道你在俄罗斯、希腊或乌克兰教堂里会看到的那种圣像，它的构图与圣像非常相似，而且女王，东正教圣像所具有的那种特质，也就是它们非常超凡脱俗，它们刻意不追求自然主义，不表现出任何情绪之类的东西，我的意思是，这种风格似乎很适合女王，不是吗？因为她一直以来既是一个象征，又是一个有血有肉的个性。
Well, she doesn't have a lot to say. So, I mean, that's kind of the point of her. But that is kind of the point of her, isn't it? I mean. Yeah, of course. You know, you kind of get intimations that in private she's capable. Absolute laugh a minute. Well, I think, was it Tommy?
好吧，她并没有太多的话要说。所以，我的意思是，这正是她的意义所在。但这就是她的意义所在，不是吗？我的意思是。是的，当然。你知道，你会从暗示中感觉到，在私底下她其实很有趣。绝对是个活宝。好吧，我想，那是汤米吗？
Is it Tommy Lascelles or Laskelles? Yeah, Tommy Lascelles or Laskelles? Yeah, Tommy Lascelles. Tommy Lascelles said that she's, something like, she's not funny, but she's quite a good sport. Did he say that on The Crown? No, I think, well, no, he actually, well, I'm quoting from a book that I read in preparation for this, Robert Hardman's Queen of the World, The Global Biography. Actually, he's talking in our festival. Is he? Well, okay. So he could probably absolutely nail that. But his book is, I mean, essentially is a kind of elaboration on this theme, the idea that she's not just the Queen of England, or indeed of the United Kingdom, Great Britain and Northern Ireland, or indeed the head of
是汤米·拉塞尔斯还是拉克斯勒斯？是的，汤米·拉塞尔斯还是拉克斯勒斯？是的，汤米·拉塞尔斯。汤米·拉塞尔斯说过，她，大概是说，她不好笑，但她很会配合。他在《王冠》里说过这话吗？不，我想，嗯，不，他其实，嗯，我是在引用一本书，为了准备这次节目我读的一本书，罗伯特·哈德曼的《世界女王：全球传记》。事实上，他将在我们的艺术节上做演讲。是吗？好吧，好吧。所以他很可能完全能讲透这一点。但他的书是，我的意思是，本质上是对这个主题的阐述，这个观点就是她不仅仅是英国的女王，或者说大不列颠及北爱尔兰联合王国的女王，或者甚至是英联邦的元首。
the Commonwealth. But she is, as Dominic, as you said, probably the single most recognisable face to people across the globe um and in that sense perhaps has a kind of international significance that is greater than we might be you know we might we might think we've called our exhibition um power and image and then the the the portraits the painted portraits the subtitle is raw portraiture and iconography it's exactly what you're saying they they become icons they are icons yeah their time but but most monarchs weren't icons though francis i would say so most monarchs were kind of flesh and blood wow wow so what we said so our portrait exhibition we're not focusing on all monarchs we decided to be really really niche and we've gone for the seven queens regnant only so just the queens
但正如多米尼克你所说，她可能是全球各地人们辨识度最高的一张面孔，从这个意义上说，也许她具有某种国际影响力，这种影响力比我们所能想象的要大，你知道的，我们把我们的展览命名为“权力与图像”，然后，肖像，彩绘肖像，副标题是“皇家肖像画与圣像学”，这正是你所说的，它们变成了圣像，它们就是圣像，是的，在它们的时代，但是，弗朗西斯，大多数君主并不是圣像，我想说，所以大多数君主是有血有肉的人，哇，哇，所以正如我们所说，我们的肖像展并不聚焦于所有的君主，我们决定做到非常非常的细分，我们只挑选了七位女王（君主），所以只有女王，
no kings just queens so here's a question for you have you included matilda not yet it's not again it's not too late not not too late not too late and tom i know what you're going to ask have they included athelflad she wasn't a queen oh she's a queen of your heart though she absolutely she's the lady of the mercens of my heart no we could we could we could maybe do um you know how like when they had the paris salon and then they had the salon where all the pictures got rejected we could do like an alternative queens but i mean on the on the topic of the queen as a global icon, presumably she, I mean, she's the only monarch that Warhol painted. I mean, you know, there are loads of, there are lots of Queens.
没有国王，只有女王。所以这里有个问题想问你，你们把马蒂尔达收录进去了吗？还没有，不过现在还来得及，还来得及，还来得及，汤姆，我知道你要问什么，他们把埃塞尔弗莱德收录进去了吗？她不是女王，哦，不过她是你心中的女王，她绝对是，她是我心中的麦西亚女领主，不，我们，我们，我们也许可以做，你知道，就像当年他们举办巴黎沙龙，然后他们有了落选沙龙，所有画作都被拒绝的那种沙龙，我们可以做一个另类的女王，不过，我的意思是，关于女王作为全球圣像这个话题，据我所知，她是沃霍尔画过的唯一一位君主。我的意思是，你知道，有很多，有很多女王。
Yeah, he actually did other Queens. She is the Queen. He didn't do any other British monarchs because we only had, we've only had the Queen. But he kind of painted the Queen of the Netherlands. Yeah, he did. Oh, that blasts my whole theory out of the water then. come we never see that image i mean we never see that image well she's not the queen of she's not the queen of britain is she she's not as famous if people say the queen by and large they mean elizabeth ii they mean our queen yeah in america so in the
是的，他实际上画过其他女王。她才是女王。他没有画过其他英国君主，因为我们只有，我们只有这位女王。但他画过荷兰女王。是的，他画过。哦，这把我的整个理论彻底粉碎了。来吧，我们从没见过那张图像，我的意思是，我们从没见过那张图像。好吧，她不是女王，她不是英国女王，对吧？她没有那么出名，如果人们大体上说“女王”，他们指的是伊丽莎白二世，他们指的是我们的女王，是的，在美利坚，所以在
first uh every now and again in this podcast we like to bring in the naked gun films and in the first um naked gun in the first naked gun film plot, as you will no doubt recall, Francis, hinges on an attempt to assassinate the Queen. That tells you that she's immediately recognizable to an American audience because, of course, that film's for an American audience. She has a very distinctive dress style. And apparently she goes for kind of the very bright primary colors so that she can be easily seen in walkabouts and things like that and people will recognise her. So that again is a kind of an example of branding, I suppose. Well, she's surely more recognisable for longer
第一部，在这个播客里，每隔一段时间我们都喜欢引入《白头神探》系列电影，而在第一部《白头神探》中，正如你毫无疑问会记起的，弗朗西斯，第一部《白头神探》的剧情围绕着一次刺杀女王的企图展开。这说明她对于美国观众来说具有极高的辨识度，因为当然那部电影是面向美国观众的。她有着非常独特的穿衣风格。显然她喜欢选择非常鲜艳的原色，这样她在进行步行外访（Walkabout）之类的活动时就能很容易地被看到，人们也能认出她来。所以这再次成为了一种品牌塑造的例子，我想。好吧，她无疑比二十世纪任何其他世界领袖拥有更长的辨识度，
than any other world figure in the 20th century. I mean, other people were more famous for five years or something, but to have had that kind of longevity and to outlast, I don't know, Mandela, Gorbachev, Reagan, JFK, Nixon, Khrushchev, all these people she met. Elvis Presley and Marilyn Monroe to talk of the Warhol icons. But Dominic, just on the topic of the queen and and her international role is she anything more than a symbol has the role that she's played say as head of the commonwealth
比任何其他人都长。我的意思是，其他人可能只是红了五年左右，但能拥有这种长盛不衰的地位，并且熬过了，我不知道，曼德拉、戈尔巴乔夫、里根、肯尼迪、尼克松、赫鲁晓夫，所有这些她见过的人。还有猫王和玛丽莲·梦露，说到沃霍尔的圣像。但是多米尼克，就女王和她的国际角色这个话题而言，她不仅仅是一个象征吗？她所扮演的角色，比如作为英联邦元首，
was about to say head of the commonwealth yeah because she really cares about that doesn't she i think that's one thing she does care about well but what's key about it though for the people in the commonwealth that's also good branding, because essentially your monarch is also the queen. So even though she's not directly impacting government, she's the figurehead in all of these places. It's almost like it's like the ultimate social media. You're out there in all those countries anyway, regardless of having to sit on a throne there. So when the Commonwealth first gets set up, and it was George VI, so it wasn't automatic that the Queen was going to become
正要说英联邦元首呢，是的，因为她真的很在乎这一点，对吧？我认为这是她真正在乎的一件事。但是，这对英联邦人民来说关键在哪里呢？这也是很好的品牌塑造，因为本质上你的君主也是女王。所以即使她没有直接影响政府，她也是所有这些地方的精神领袖。这几乎就像是终极的社交媒体。你无论如何都在所有这些国家亮相，而不必非得在那里坐上王位。所以当英联邦最初建立时，那是乔治六世时期，所以女王成为英联邦元首并不是顺理成章的。基本上是尼赫鲁为她促成了此事。所以他发了一封祝贺电报。但是你知道用来描述乔治六世作为英联邦元首角色的那个拉丁语词汇是什么吗？请赐教。那是 princeps，也就是奥古斯都·凯撒的头衔，
head of the Commonwealth. And basically it was Nehru who swung it for her. So he sent a kind of congratulatory telegram. But do you know the Latin word that was used to describe George VI's role as head of the Commonwealth? Enlighten us. It was princeps, which is the title augustus season yeah yeah to avoid the name rex because it would have been offensive rex king in latin
是的，是的，为了避免使用 rex 这个词，因为那会令人反感，rex 在拉丁语里是国王的意思，
it would have been offensive to uh to the republic quite different characters in india augustus and george the sixth yes they are um the thing i think is really important and i think is um she has played that role with such gusto and such enthusiasm in a way that I suspect almost anybody else would have put a foot wrong, particularly during the period of decolonisation. When she played it so cleverly and she was so sensitive to kind of local sentiments in the various countries that had once been imperial kind of possessions. The next object I think kind of linked to what we were saying about her being so recognized and that's this amazing punch cartoon by e.h shepherd which was on the banner head of punch magazine the week of the coronation which was may 27 1953 um and for those listeners who don't who can't recall e.h shepherd was the famous
这对于印度的……奥古斯都和乔治六世是截然不同的性格，是的，他们是。我认为非常重要的一点，而且我认为，她以如此的热情和干劲扮演了那个角色，以至于我怀疑换作几乎任何其他人都会走错一步，尤其是在非殖民化时期。当时她处理得非常巧妙，对曾经作为帝国领地的各个国家的当地情绪非常敏感。我认为下一个物件有点契合我们之前所说的关于她备受认可这一点，那是E·H·谢泼德（E.H. Shepard）创作的一幅精彩的《笨拙》（Punch）杂志漫画，那是1953年5月27日加冕周那一期《笨拙》杂志的封面横幅，对于那些记不清的听众来说，E·H·谢泼德是《小熊维尼》和《柳林风声》的著名插画家，他创作了一个精彩的设计，里面有屹耳、蟾蜍庄园的蟾蜍先生穿着（你知道的）王室长袍，有维尼在试戴王冠，有小猪在研究《德布雷特贵族世家谱》以做准备，而多米尼克，我们有猫头鹰，你曾被《泰晤士报》拿来和它做比较。我其实很想提起这件事，所以我很高兴你选择了这个，弗朗西斯，因为《泰晤士报》对这个播客进行了评论，说汤姆就像跳跳虎，而我就像博学多才的猫头鹰。
illustrator of winnie the pooh and wind in the willows and there's an amazing design he did where you've got eeyore toad of toad hall dressing up in you know regal robes you've got poo trying on a crown you've got piglets studying de bretts just to get ready and dominic we've got owl to whom you were compared by the times i wanted to bring this up actually so i was very pleased that you chose this, Francis, because the Times reviewed this podcast and said that Tom was like Tigger and that I was like Al Wise and Skelly.
而我真的……跳跳虎没在这个上面。跳跳虎没在这个上面，汤姆。跳跳虎甚至连出现在横幅上的分量都没有。你知道，我觉得我们不应该做这个。而且那篇评论发表的早晨，我在WhatsApp上收到了汤姆发来的一条消息，时间是在一个不合时宜的清晨，比如早上6点31分，上面写着：“我简直不敢相信他们叫你猫头鹰，这绝对太离谱了，你根本不是猫头鹰，你是屹耳。”好吧，而且屹耳也在上面，他也在上面。无论如何，
And I was really... Tigger's not on this. Tigger's not on this, Tom. Tigger's not even significant enough to be on the banner. Do you know, I don't think we should do this one. And the morning that review came out, i had a message from tom on my whatsapp at kind of some ungodly hour like 6 31 a.m saying i can't believe they called you owl this is absolutely outrageous you're not owl at all you're eeyore well and eeyore's there as well he's there as well anyway
嗯，所以不管怎样，除了让我们想起《泰晤士报》上这篇精彩的评论之外，你为什么会选择这幅漫画呢？我选择这个的观点是，我认为在英国的集体，我不知道是集体知识中，如果你愿意的话，在女王的统治期间，很少有角色像女王那样具有辨识度，而我某种程度上认为这些角色，E·H·谢泼德画的小熊维尼，它们一定是最具辨识度的，不仅对过去的几代人来说是这样，而且现在的孩子们仍然……不过汤姆对此有个理论。好的，所以——所以我觉得某种程度上它说明了相反的情况，因为我认为这些是爱德华时期的形象，这些形象非常明确地属于第二次世界大战之前，
um so anyway apart from reminding us of this splendid um notice in the times why did you choose this this cartoon so my point about this is i think in kind of british collective i don't know collective knowledge if you like um in the queen's reign there are a few characters as recognizable as the queen and i kind of think these characters eh shepherds drawings of poo they've got to be the most recognizable just for you know generations past but also kids today still well tom has a theory about this okay so so i i think in a way it illustrates the opposite because i think these are edwardian figures um these are figures um very much certainly of the before the second world war
而且我想说，如果现在人们想到小熊维尼，他们会想到迪士尼的角色，而不是E·H·谢泼德的版本。我对此有过很大的抱怨，但我认为——他在迪士尼里确实带着美国口音，对吧？是的，是的。所以对我来说，这总结了
and i would say that the image people if people think of Winnie the Pooh now, they're going to think of the Disney character rather than the Eighth Shepherd. I've had a massive kind of, you know, grumble about this, but I think- He does have an American accent in Disney, doesn't he? Yes, yes. So what this sums up for me
女王到底有多老。我知道当她在庆祝白金禧年时，这是一个非常显而易见的说法。所以在阅读这本《世界女王》时，有一件事让我印象深刻，她第一次出国是在1947年，当时她20岁。那是和国王以及后来的王后一起去南非。当她在那里的时候，
is just how old the Queen is. I mean, I know that's a really obvious thing to say when she's celebrating her Platinum Jubilee. So one of the things that struck me reading this book on Queen of the World, she first travels abroad when she's 20 in 1947. And it's to South Africa with the king and then queen. And while she's out there,
她遇到了一大批布尔战争的老兵，其中一些人实际上是曾经与英国人作战的布尔人。但其中一个人，多米尼克，你会对这个感到兴奋的，其中一个人，他在戈尔德阵亡的那一年去过苏丹。哦，天哪。所以他曾随远征队去救援戈尔德将军。是的。所以女王遇到过曾参加过那次远征的人。在2022年，这甚至让人觉得不可思议，这竟然是可能的。那个人竟然还是国家元首的君主。
she meets a whole load of veterans of the Burr War, some of whom are actually Burrs who fought against the British. But one of them, and Dominic, you'll be excited about this, one of them, he'd been in Sudan in the year that Gordon died. Oh, my word. So he'd been on the expedition to rescue General Gordon. Yeah. So the Queen met somebody who'd been on that expedition. And it just seems insane in 2022 that that would even be possible. That that person is still the monarch of the head of state.
是的。是的。当然，我的意思是，她的第一位首相是温斯顿·丘吉尔，我的意思是，丘吉尔是一位维多利亚时代的人，出生于维多利亚时代。而她成长过程中必定接触过的人，嗯，她成长过程中读过的儿童读物，你知道的，都会是维多利亚时代的、爱德华时期的。他们在白金汉宫换岗，但
Yeah. Yeah. Well, of course, I mean, her first prime minister was Winston Churchill, who's, I mean, Churchill was a Victorian, born in the Victorian era. And the people that she must have grown up with, well, the children's books that she read, you know, when she was growing up would have been Victorian, Edwardianian they're changing guard at buckingham palace but isn't
这难道不是她的意义所在吗？她就像是一座桥梁，不仅连接到她早年的人生，还是一座贯穿历史的桥梁，你知道的，她是七位女王中的第七位，是的，当然。也许这就是我顺便介绍我的下一件藏品的地方，我们借用了她的一本加冕圣经。哦，现在汤姆对此非常兴奋。但展示她的加冕圣经的意义在于，这可以追溯到伊丽莎白一世女王的加冕圣经，以及这如何成为一种传统，
that also her point that she is like this bridge not only to the early part of her life but also a bridge through history you know she's the seventh of the seven queens right yeah of course maybe this is where i can slot in my next object, which is we've borrowed one of her coronation Bibles. Oh, now Tom's very excited about this. But the point of showing one of her coronation Bibles is that links back to Queen Elizabeth I's coronation Bible and how that's sort of become a thing,
即所有的君主都有一本特殊的加冕圣经。我想对很多人来说，他们可能会想，好吧，你知道，为什么你需要一本特殊的圣经？为什么你不能直接用普通的圣经呢？我想这也展现了我们宏大庆典的精细程度。你知道，我们不能就用同一本圣经。好吧，最关键的是，在我们深入探讨圣经之前，对大多数人来说，女王的核心意义恰恰在于，正如你所说，我会说，她是与过去世代相连的化身，她是传统的化身，这就是为什么实际上，压抑她的个性一直如此重要，因为这能让你只把她看作是历史的某种化身，是的，
that all monarchs have a special coronation Bible. And I think to lots of people, they might think, well, you know, why do you need a special? Why can't you just use the normal Bible? I suppose it also shows the degree of detail of our pageantry. You know, we can't just use the same Bible. Well, the whole point is, before we get into the Bible, the whole point of the Queen to most people is that she's precisely, as you say, I would say, that she is an embodiment of a link with generations that have gone before she's the incarnation of tradition and that's why actually um suppressing her personality has been so important because it allows you just to see her as this kind of avatar of of history yeah um the other thing about the bible i think
关于圣经的另一件事，我认为你需要一本非常特殊的圣经，我的意思是，你不会在你的……使用《好消息圣经》，我的意思是，查尔斯王子可能会，但我无论如何都不会赞同的，汤姆，我知道你想谈谈圣经。好吧，我的意思是，它要古老得多，我认为这显然要追溯得更久远，甚至比英国君主制或英格兰君主制的建立还要久远，我的意思是，这把我们直接带回了旧约中国王和女王的受膏仪式。这提醒我们，加冕仪式，对于女王来说，它是一个圣礼，是一个具有圣礼性质的仪式。我认为她完全认真对待它，一直以来都非常非常虔诚地对待它。我认为她完全
you would have to have very particular bible i mean you're not going to use the good news bible at your um i mean prince charles might but i wouldn't approve of it anyway tom um i know you want to talk about bibles well i mean it's much old i think it goes back obviously much much further than than even the foundation of the british monarchy or the english monarchy i mean this is taking us right back to uh the anointing of kings and queens in the Old Testament. And it's a reminder that the coronation ritual, you know, for the queen, it's a sacrament, it's a sacramental ritual. And I think she takes it completely, you know, has taken it completely seriously. She's very, very devout Christian. I think she completely
相信这一点。再次我认为，这是她那种如果可以的话属于她的古老感的一个方面，因为我认为她有一个，你知道的，她相信——我敢说——加冕仪式的神圣品质，因此作为受膏君主的角色，我想象大概只有一小部分她忠实的臣民现在仍然这样认为。好吧，这就是为什么当摄像机进入时，摄像机不允许捕捉那些最亲密的时刻。是的，因为这是一个绝对神圣、神圣的时刻。我在想，你知道的，当新国王加冕和受膏的时刻到来时，人们对这一切究竟会作何感想。
believes it. And again, I think that that is an aspect of if you like her kind of antiquity because i think she has a you know she she she believes in dare i say the sacral quality of the coronation ritual and therefore as her her role as an anointed monarch in a way that i would imagine only capital loft of her loyal subjects probably still does. Well, that's why when they had the cameras in, the cameras weren't allowed to capture the most intimate moments. Yeah, because it's an absolutely sacred, sacred moment. I wonder whether, you know, when the time comes for the new king to be crowned and anointed, quite what people will make of all this.
但他自己，他想成为信仰的捍卫者，不是吗？好吧，他的确想。而女王，我的意思是，女王对此也完全乐见其成。我的意思是，她显然非常虔诚，并致力于她作为英格兰教会最高元首的角色。但她同时也非常乐于接受多元信仰的一面，尤其是英联邦的多元信仰，因为，你知道的，英联邦里穆斯林和印度教徒的数量比基督徒还要多。所以她从未对此有过问题。事实上，多米尼克，我们在周一有一个要在圣马田教堂举办的慈善活动。事实上，1966年在圣马田教堂曾举行过一次多元信仰的庆祝活动，以庆祝英联邦中许多不同的信仰，那
But he himself, he wants to be a defender of faith, doesn't he? Well, he does. And the Queen, I mean, the Queen is perfectly happy with that as well. I mean, she clearly is very devout and committed to her role as Supreme Governor of the Church of England. But she's also perfectly happy with the multi-faith aspect, particularly of the Commonwealth, because, you know, there are more Muslims and Hindus in the Commonwealth than there are Christians. So she's never had a problem with that. And in fact, Dominic, we've got our charity thing that we're doing at St. Martin-in-the-Fields on Monday. And actually, there was a multi-faith celebration in St. Martin-in-the-Fields in 1966 to celebrate the many different faiths of the commonwealth that
引发了相当大的争议，并遭到了主教们的强烈反对，所以女王，威斯敏斯特教堂是一个王家特权教堂，所以基本上她可以在那里为所欲为，是的，所以现在他们在威斯敏斯特教堂举办这种英联邦的，你知道的，精神庆祝活动，也许这只是她，这只是她对待信仰的方式，正如你所说，她能完全对其他所有人的信仰感同身受，这也正是让她作为英联邦元首如此强大的原因，绝对的，我想，我认为绝对是这样，她因为相信，因为她内心深处是一位基督徒，对自己的信仰感到如此满足和扎根，所以别人的信仰根本不是问题，我认为现在，我的意思是，我们生活在一个充满“今日灵粮”式的世界里，我应该为非英国听众解释一下，这是一个早间新闻里的广播时段，
generated quite a lot of controversy and the lot of blowback from bishops on this and so the queen has uh westminster abbey is a royal peculiar so basically she do what she likes with it yeah so so now they have these kind of commonwealth um you know spiritual celebrations in the westminster abbey maybe it's just her it's just her approach to faith as you say she can totally empathize with everyone else's faith which is what makes us so powerful as the head of the commonwealth too absolutely i think i think that's absolutely it she because she believes in because she's so deeply christian and so content and and rooted in her faith other people's faith are not an issue i think that that now i mean we we live in a kind of thought for the day world i should explain for non-british listeners this is a a radio slot on
来自不同信仰传统的各种各样的人都会上节目，说完全相同的话，他们基本上说的就是当你六岁时你的女校长对你说的话，我认为因此它就不具备了，因此它的效力大大降低了。而且事实上它是一个非常新教的仪式。我的意思是，另一件事我认为人们会觉得相当奇怪。这是一个相当宗派化的仪式。同样，追溯到伊丽莎白一世，我的意思是，她是一位新教女王。好吧，我们借来的其中一幅肖像画是苏格兰女王玛丽的肖像。我想回到圣经上来，我认为关于这本惊人的圣经最了不起的事情之一就是，这一切都体现在这个非常私密的物品中。你知道，我们要记住，过去的图书，那是拥有精美装订、手绘插图抄本的终极奢侈品。
the uh on the morning news where various people from different faith traditions all come on and say exactly the same they basically say exactly the thing that your headmistress says when you're six and i think that therefore it has a you therefore it has much less kind of potency. And also the fact that it's a very Protestant ritual. I mean, that's the other thing that I think people will find quite odd. It's quite a sectarian ritual. And again, going back to Elizabeth I, I mean, she was a Protestant queen. Well, one of the portraits that we've borrowed is one of Mary, Queen of Scots. And I think going back to the Bible, I think one of the amazing things about an amazing Bible is all of that is summed up in this very intimate object. You know, we've got to remember books back in the day, that was the ultimate luxury object to have a beautifully bound, illuminated manuscript.
这本圣经有多少年历史了？为了加冕典礼，曾有一系列，制作了25个特殊版本？为了加冕典礼，曾有一系列，制作了25个特殊版本来纪念加冕。所以对于书籍来说，一切都在于装订。这些装订是由英国20世纪最著名的装订商之一设计和制作的，他们被称为桑戈斯基与萨特克利夫（Zaehnsdorf and Sutcliffe）。他们成立于1901年。他们拥有王室认证。
How old is this Bible? For the coronation, there was a series. There were 25 special copies made? For the coronation, there was a series. There were 25 special copies made to mark the coronation. And so with books, it's all about bindings. And the bindings were created and designed by probably the most famous 20th century binders in Britain, people called Zangorski and Sutcliffe. They were established in 1901. They've got the Royal Warrant.
1953年的圣经，它上面其实有一个相当酷的几何图案，所以我想这反映了，这只是一种手写的，是的，这是非常50年代风格的，是的，这是一个非常50年代的设计，不是吗？然后还有一个大教堂，你绝对不会错过它，它是王室专属的，因为上面大约有15个皇冠，这是《詹姆士王钦定本》吗？不可能别的。是的，绝对不可能别的。用《好消息圣经》来加冕简直荒谬。
And the 1953 Bible, it's actually got quite a cool geometric pattern on it so i suppose it reflects that's just a sort of written yeah it's very 50s kind of yeah it's very 50s um design isn't it and then there's a cathedral you can't miss that it's regal because there's about 15 crowns on it and is it the King James version? It can't be any other. Yeah, it can't be any other. It would be ludicrous to use the Good News Bible to be crowned.
它可能是修订标准版或者别的什么，我不知道。我想你必须使用《詹姆士王钦定本》，对吧？不用它简直太不英国了。当查尔斯成为国王时，对我和我来说，这将是绝对的试金石，
It could be Revised Stan version or I don't know, whatever. I think you've got to use the King James, haven't you? I think it's un-British not to. When Charles becomes king, this to me will be the absolute litmus test
来检验我是否支持他。当然，你无论如何都不会支持他，因为你有据可查地表示过，在继承危机中你支持的是爱德华王子，我是，我有据可查地是他的旗手，是的，我觉得他会是一个出色的，我觉得他会是一个出色的国王，这难道只是因为他是老幺吗？不，是因为他对汤姆说过他显然对所有遇到的作家都说过的话：“我很喜欢你的书”，所以我现在已经向他宣誓效忠了，是的，老实说，
to whether I support him. And of course, you don't support him anyway because you're on record as saying in a succession crisis you're backing Prince Edwardward i am i'm on record as being his banner man yes i think he'd be a wonderful i think he'd be a wonderful king it's just is that just because he's the youngest no it's because he said to tom what he clearly says to all writers that he meets i enjoyed your book so i'm now i've pledged my sword to him yeah and i shall be honest
我想在他见到你几秒钟前，有人在他耳边低语：汤姆·霍兰德，作家，不是蜘蛛侠。行了，少来这套……说真的，多米尼克。好了，我想我们现在该休息一下了。休息过后，我们会带来更多冷静的……根正苗红的节目。
i think seconds before he met you, someone whispered in his ear, Tom Holland, author, not Spider-Man. Yeah, that's enough of your... Honestly, Dominic. Right, I think we should take a break now. We will see you after the break for more sober... Right royal.
对，根正苗红。我们表现得挺好。我想我们已经完成了一半。我们已经完成了一半了。我们已经讲完了苏富比关于女王及其禧年的精彩展览中前六大展品的一半，休息过后我们将为你带来另外三件展品。
Yeah, right royal. We've done quite well. We've done half of them, I think. We've done halfway. We're halfway through the top six artifacts from Sotheby's exciting exhibition about the Queen and her Jubilee. And we'll see you after the break for three more.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。在前半段节目中，正如你可能记得的那样，我们以非常深刻和严肃的方式探讨了弗朗西斯·克里斯蒂为他们关于禧年和伊丽莎白二世女王生平时代的精彩展览所精心挑选的前三件展品。现在，弗朗西斯，你要用第四件展品给我们带来惊喜了。第四件是什么？因为我们在前半段表现得太严肃了，所以也许我们应该挑选一件真正具有争议性的作为第一件。那是今年晚些时候，我们将会展出它，
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. In the first half, as you may remember, we dealt in a very profound and serious way with the three first artefacts that Francis Christie has chosen for their exciting exhibition about the Jubilee and about the life and times of Queen Elizabeth II. And now, Francis, you're going to surprise us with number four. So what's number four? Because we were so serious in the first half that maybe we should go for like proper controversial as the first one. And that's later on the year, we'll be exhibiting it,
但我们会在今年晚些时候出售它。这是杰米·里德为性手枪乐队创作的著名设计之一。那是他们的《天佑女王》海报，在这张海报中，对于那些不了解这张海报的人来说，杰米·里德采用了一张由塞西尔·比顿拍摄的女王陛下的极其庄重的照片。他基本上对它进行了涂鸦，用新闻字体涂掉了她的眼睛和嘴巴，上面写着“天佑女王”，然后在她的嘴巴上方写着“性手枪”。接着他把它
but we're selling it later on the year. It's one of Jamie Reed's famous designs for the Sex Pistols. And it's their God Save the Queen poster, in which, for those who don't know the poster, Jamie Reid took a very staid photo of Her Majesty the Queen by Cecil Beaton. And he essentially graffitied it, graffitied out her eyes and her mouth using news type, which say God Save the Queen and then the Sex Pistols over her mouth. And then he mounted it
裱在了一面英国国徽旗上。所以这是1977年，这是银禧年，不是吗？这也是朋克音乐和性手枪乐队引发的道德恐慌以及歌曲《天佑女王》的顶峰。好吧，我的意思是，关于它是否真的达到了第二名的巅峰，或者是否存在阻止它登上排行榜榜首的邪恶阴谋，仍然存在一些争论。我本人其实对阴谋论持一点怀疑态度。但是汤姆，你是性手枪乐队的超级粉丝吗？我赞赏他们曾经存在过。
on a Union Jack. So this is 1977 it's the year of the silver jubilee isn't it it's also the peak of kind of the moral panic over punk and over the sex pistols and the song God Save the Queen well I mean there's still some debate about whether it really peaked at number two or whether there was an evil conspiracy to stop it from getting to the top of the charts. I'm actually a little bit sceptical about the conspiracy theory myself. But Tom, are you a big Sex Pistols fan? I approve of them having happened.
你能唱《天佑女王》吗，鉴于你在开头唱过？天佑女王，法西斯政权，她绝不是人类。我不记得剩下的了。是的。差不多吧。这不是苏富比想要记住的——剩下的话，是的，差不多吧。那不是苏富比想要传达的信息，是的，不，不，那不是那个信息，那是约翰尼·罗顿唱的，当然，那是一次非常棒的模仿，非常感谢，
Can you sing God Save the Queen, seeing that you sang at the beginning? God Save the Queen, the fascist regime, she ain't no human being. I can't remember the rest. Yeah. Something like that. That's not the message that Souther is wanting remember the rest yeah something like that that's not the message that suther is wanting yeah no no that's not the message that was that was johnny rotten of course that was a very good impersonation thank you very much
嗯，所以这说明了什么？我的意思是，这表明，嗯，她绝不是人类，所以这是将女王用作——这不太算讽刺，对吧？因为这在讽刺什么，或者它是在讽刺女王崇拜吗？你觉得把它和沃霍尔的作品放在一起思考会很有趣吗？是的，它某种程度上是在呼应，我猜，你知道，即使你看不到她的眼睛，嘴巴（你知道那是女王），那也是权力的图像的呼应——王冠，甚至不用看到眼睛和嘴巴，你知道那是女王，这很有趣，不是吗？性手枪乐队选择向女王抗争，而不是首相，是的，但这是因为那是银禧年，因为每个人都在举行，你知道的，
um so what does this show i mean it shows that um well she ain't no human being so this is the use of the queen as as it's not quite satire is it because what's it satirizing or is it satirizing the cult of the queen would you say it's quite interesting to think about the warhol yeah it's kind of playing off i suppose you know even if you can't it's playing off both that image of power the tiara even without seeing her eyes the mouth you know that's the queen and it's interesting isn't it that the sex pistols chose to kick against the queen not a prime minister and yeah but it was because it's a silver jubilee and because everyone's being kind of you know
根正苗红的园游会和街头派对以及所有这类活动，而这些正是茶巾之类东西的题材，然后他们还有那艘船，还记得银禧年周末的那艘船吗，它载着马尔科姆·麦克laren航行过去，大声播放着音乐驶过威斯敏斯特宫，这有点像是在向当权者挑衅，或者我猜在这个案例中是向女性挑衅，我的意思是，这很有趣。我当时在想，这其实表明在英国我们真的很幸运，因为，她的统治一直是英国创造力的一次大爆发，但我想，也是言论自由的一次大爆发。
right royal garden parties and street parties and all that kind of stuff and and this is the kind of stuff of tea towels and then and then they have the boat remember the boat on on the silver jubilee weekend that sailed past with mark mclaren and yeah blaring it out past the palace of westminster it's kind of sticking it to the man isn't it or i suppose in this case the woman i mean that's the fun of it i was thinking it shows actually in britain we're really lucky in that, I mean, her reign has been this massive explosion of British creativity, but also, I guess, freedom of speech.
人们可以想出他们想出的任何东西。是的。这很酷。当时引发了巨大的争议。所以你想知道大伦敦议会（GLC）保守党法律与秩序发言人对这张图像是怎么说的吗？他是否赞成将其作为对言论自由和艺术自我表达的庆祝？他说这绝对血腥恶心。你想知道工党议员马库斯·利普顿是怎么说的吗？他说了什么？他说，嗯，
People can come up with whatever they want to come up with. Yeah. And that's cool. There was a huge controversy at the time. So do you want to know what the Conservative Law and Order spokesman of the GLC, the Greater London Council, said said about this image was he in favor of it as a celebration of free speech an artistic self-expression he said it was absolutely bloody revolting do you want to know what the labor mp marcus lipton said about it what did he say said uh
人们可以想创作什么就创作什么。是的。这很酷。当时引起了巨大的争议。你想知道大伦敦议会（GLC）保守党法律与秩序发言人对这张照片说了什么吗？他是否赞成将其作为言论自由和艺术自我表达的庆祝活动？他说这绝对是血腥的可恶。你想知道工党议员马库斯·利普顿对它说了什么吗？他说什么了？他说，呃
if pop music is going to be used to destroy our established institutions then pop music ought to be destroyed first i don't know how would you destroy how would you destroy pop music i don't know simon cowell yes exactly maybe he was playing a very long game very very long game i mean this is so this is i mean it's kind of this kind of oedipal sequence where artists react against predecessors. So the Sex Pistols are famous to do that with the Rock and Roll Swindle. Yeah. That long list of rock stars who they hate. Who was the one who got chucked out for liking the Beatles?
如果流行音乐要被用来摧毁我们既有的体制，那么流行音乐首先就应该被摧毁。我不知道，你会怎么摧毁？你会怎么摧毁流行音乐？我不知道，西蒙·考威尔？对，完全正确。也许他在下一盘很大的棋，一盘非常非常大的棋。我的意思是，这有点像那种俄狄浦斯式的序列，艺术家们会对抗前辈。所以性手枪乐队做“摇滚骗局”时就很有名。对。他们讨厌的摇滚明星长长名单。哪个家伙因为喜欢披头士而被开除了？
Oh, is it Glenn Matlock? Was it Glenn Matlock? One of them supposedly got thrown out for liking the Beatles. But the thing with the queen though that's interesting though is that this has only happened once so in the whole course of her reign and we're up to the platinum jubilee now and in all that time this is really the only moment i can think of where there's been a cultural backlash yeah against i mean obviously there have been moments when her popularity is dipped but this is the only time i can think of where
哦，是格伦·马特洛克吗？是格伦·马特洛克吗？他们当中好像有人因为喜欢披头士而被踢出了乐队。但关于女王，有趣的地方在于，这种情况只发生过一次。在她统治的整个历程中——我们现在迎来了白金禧年——在所有这些时间里，这是我能想到的唯一一个真正遭到文化反弹的时刻。对，我是说，显然有过她的民望下跌的时刻，但这真的是我能想到的唯一一个
there have been images like this but i would say it's not a reaction really against the queen it's the queen is icon isn't it yeah and it's the queen it's the queen so she's photographed by cecil beaton yeah who is a kind of the the representative of a previous generation of artists he's like the ultimate sort of staid society photographer that that's what they're reacting against rather than her herself he used to be my next door neighbor Cecil Beaton yeah you're old enough to have lived next door to Cecil Beaton he he um he had this huge queen and house in Broadchalk the village I grew up in and we had the house next door to it did your son has kicker bought on he wouldn't have kicked more you'd have well you you remember we set up the cricket net on the day that the Falklands wall broke out.
出现过这种画面的时刻。不过我要说，这其实不是针对女王的反应，女王是一个偶像，对吧？是的，它是女王，是女王，所以她是由塞西尔·比顿拍摄的。是的，他是前一代艺术家的某种代表，他就像那种终极的、刻板的社会摄影师，这才是他们反抗的对象，而不是她本人。塞西尔·比顿以前是我的邻居。塞西尔·比顿，是的。你老到能和塞西尔·比顿做邻居了吗？他，嗯，他在我长大的那个叫布罗德乔克的村子里有一栋巨大的女王风格的房子，我们的房子就在它隔壁。你的儿子有……踢过球吗？他不会踢更多的，你……嗯，你还记得我们在福克兰群岛战争爆发的那天搭起了板网吗？
I do remember. And we would occasionally hit a cricket ball or kick a football over the wall so that we could go and explore Cecil Beaton's garden. He was very nice. He didn't mind it at all. Occasionally we'd run into him and he'd just beam at us cheerfully. So I'm very, very pro Cecil Beaton. Okay. So you deplore this cover?
我确实记得。我们偶尔会把板球或足球打过墙，这样我们就可以去探索塞西尔·比顿的花园了。他非常好。他一点也不介意。我们偶尔会撞见他，他只是开心地冲我们笑。所以我非常非常支持塞西尔·比顿。好吧。所以你痛恨这个封面？
Yes, I probably do. No, well, no, I Cecil Beatton. Okay. So you deplore this cover? Yes, I probably do. No, well, no, I'm sure he enjoyed it. Okay. So the sex, I mean, that's probably one of the most celebrated images of the Queen. What it is mocking, though, is not the person Elizabeth Windsor. It is mocking people. It's actually not even mocking the monarchy. It's mocking people's reverence for the monarchy, which is something different.
是的，我可能确实如此。不，好吧，不，我……塞西尔·比顿。好吧。所以你痛恨这个封面？是的，我可能确实如此。不，好吧，不，我确信他会喜欢它。好吧。所以，这种性，我的意思是，这可能是女王最著名的形象之一。然而，它嘲弄的不是伊丽莎白·温莎这个人。它嘲弄的是人们。实际上它甚至不是在嘲弄君主制。它嘲弄的是人们对君主制的崇拜，这是完全不同的东西。
And sort of, I think it's mocking, yeah, establishment. And I think also the reason why I sort of wanted to talk about it, it also again shows, goes back to this idea of the power of imagery. Yeah. Like a very subtle tweak, you know, to her eyes and her mouth. To me, it's not, it's a comic image in some ways, rather than a genuinely angry. It is funny.
并且某种程度上，我认为它嘲弄的是，是的，建制派。而且我认为我之所以想谈论它，也是因为它再次展示了、回到了影像力量这个概念上。是的。就像对她的眼睛和嘴巴进行非常微妙的微调。对我来说，它不是，在某些方面它是一个滑稽的形象，而不是一种真正的愤怒。它很有趣。
I mean, it is just funny. It's not, it's silly rather than, it's not genuinely scathing or subversive. I wouldn't say. Yeah. It's not like, do you remember when, was it such and such, you did that campaign and Tony Blair's eyes were slit into evil eyes.
我的意思是，它就是很有趣。它不是，它更多是恶搞，而不是真正尖锐或颠覆性的。我不会这么说。是的。这不像，你还记得当年，是哪个来着，你做了那个竞选活动，托尼·布莱尔的眼睛被割成了邪恶的眼睛。
Demonize new labor, new danger. Well, I mean, and as far as I know, I mean, the queen has never been kind of burnt in effigy or paraded through streets hanging from a gibbet or anything like that that occasionally happens in you know the streets of
妖魔化新工党，新危险。好吧，我的意思是，据我所知，女王从来没有被做成纸扎人焚烧过，也没有像有时在……比如……的街道上那样，被悬挂在绞刑架上游街示众
Lewis for instance yeah no she hasn't and actually if you did that it would be genuinely shocking do you not think yeah you could burn anybody else you could burn Tony Blair has been burned in effigy and he's always been burned in effigy it's sort of fireworks displays next to Donald Trump or something but no one would burn the Queen, and it would be really, really... Yes, I think people would be genuinely shocked by that. I also think it's quite cool because it shows that connection between music and art, such a major thing that Jamie Reid and Malcolm Clarendon...
刘易斯镇之类的地方，是的，不，她没有。事实上，如果你那样做，那将是真正令人震惊的，你不觉得吗？是的，你可以烧掉任何其他人。你可以烧掉托尼·布莱尔，他一直被做成纸扎人焚烧，在唐纳德·特朗普或类似人物旁边的烟花表演中，他总是被焚烧，但没有人会烧女王，而且这会真的、真的……是的，我认为人们会对此感到真正的震惊。我也觉得这很酷，因为它展示了音乐和艺术之间的联系，这是杰米·里德和马尔科姆·麦克拉伦的一件大事……
I think that's really interesting there, though, Frances, is that... So, 77, when you had the Silver Jubilee, the monarchy was about the last institution imaginable that would ever embrace that sort of pop music art nexus. I mean, when they had the Jubilee, it was as far away removed from the sort of pop culture of the day as could be imagined. And yet you go forward to 2002 or 2012 and the Jubilees then, whoever their spin doctors were pulled a blinded and they were brian may on this and the roof of buckingham palace and elton john and paul mccartney and all these characters sort of the monarchy one of the great secrets i think of us of its success in
弗朗西斯，我认为真正有趣的是……所以，在77年，当你庆祝银禧时，君主制几乎是你能想象到的最后一个会拥抱这种流行音乐与艺术结合的机构。我的意思是，当他们举办禧年时，它与当天的流行文化可以说是相去甚远。然而，到了2002年或2012年以及那时的禧年，无论他们的形象策划是谁，都打出了一张王牌，他们在白金汉宫屋顶上有布莱恩·梅，还有埃尔顿·约翰和保罗·麦卡特尼以及所有这些人物，某种程度上，君主制——我认为这是它近年来成功的一大秘诀——
recent years has been the way that it's basically appropriated the energies of popular culture rather than setting itself up as a in resistance. Which is what the Queen essentially did with the Commonwealth, to go back to that, that all these kind of revolutionaries and radicals who'd been locked up in prison, you invite them along to a grand banquet and the Queen's charming to them and they all go weak at the knees. I mean, I think that is a definite kind of tendency. Frances, do you have any other object that might in any way link the Queen
在于它基本上吸收了大众文化的能量，而不是将自己置于对立面。这就是女王对英联邦本质上所做的事情，回到这一点，所有这些曾被关在监狱里的革命者和激进分子，你邀请他们参加盛大的宴会，女王对他们很有魅力，他们都双腿发软。我的意思是，我认为这是一种明确的倾向。弗朗西斯，你还有什么其他物品能以某种方式将女王
to giants of rock music? The one painting, which again, I'll describe it because people can't see it. I wanted to bring into this mix is a painting by Frank Auerbach. It's a head of Goethe-Bohm from 1965, but famously it belonged to David Bowie. So it doesn't really have anything to do on the surface with the Queen. But hear me out. Or judging by the picture with the head of gerda boom so it's it's it's for those who who can't immediately conjure up what this picture is um it's an abstracted head of his cousin gerda boom he painted for over 20 years
与摇滚乐巨星联系起来吗?这幅画，同样，我会描述它，因为人们看不见它。我想带入这个组合的是弗兰克·奥尔巴赫的一幅画。这是1965年格达·博姆的头像，但众所周知它曾属于大卫·鲍伊。所以它表面上和女王没有任何关系。但听我解释。或者从盖达·博姆头像的照片来看，对于那些无法立刻在脑海中勾勒出这幅画的人来说，嗯，这是他表妹盖达·博姆的抽象头像，他画了20多年
and with all of his sitters they would come for the same two hours the same day every single week and he'd look at them and look at them he would put paint onto a board or a canvas he'd take the paint off he'd scrape it off he'd add it on and he was trying to capture the essence of them so it is quite abstracted there's so much paint that you almost if you get up close it looks like a kind of sculpture of oil but then a bit like when you do a magic eye painting if you move further back and you squint your eyes a bit um you can see that there is a head so david bowie said about it hung at the end of his corridor so he saw it every morning when he got up and every evening when he went to bed and he said i want to sound like that looks wow and so what is
对于他所有的模特来说，他们每周的同一天都会来相同的两个小时，他会看着他们，看着他们，他会把颜料涂在木板或画布上，他会把颜料拿下来，他会把它刮掉，他会把它加上去，他试图捕捉他们的精髓，所以它是相当抽象的，有那么多的颜料，如果你走近一点，你几乎会觉得它是一种油画雕塑，但随后就像你做一幅魔幻眼画一样，如果你往后退一点，稍微眯起眼睛，嗯，你可以看到有一个头像。所以大卫·鲍伊这样评价它：它挂在他的走廊尽头，所以他每天早上起床和每天晚上睡觉时都能看到它，他说：“我想让我的声音听起来就像这幅画看起来的那样。”哇。那么，
the link what what links this to the queen so I think this links the period in which Auerbach and Bowie came to prominence in a way. It's a Britain that in the post-war period that was, you know, huge post-war angst. She picked up the reins in the early 50s just as we were rising from the embers of the Blitz. That's when Auerbach came as a refugee to London. And I think it's her reign which set the stage for amazing people like Bowie, who he was the ultimate shapeshifter in a time where all of these different shapes that he shifted, they weren't necessarily,
有什么联系呢？是什么将它与女王联系起来呢？所以我认为这在某种程度上联系了奥尔巴赫和鲍伊崭露头角的时期。这是一个战后时期的英国，你知道的，有着巨大的战后焦虑。她在50年代初接过权杖，正当我们从闪电战的余烬中崛起时。那是奥尔巴赫作为难民来到伦敦的时候。我认为正是她的统治为像鲍伊这样了不起的人物奠定了基础，在那个时代，他终极的变装大师身份——所有这些他所变换的不同的形象，它们不一定是被……
they weren't accepted. And he made it, he sort of blazed that path. And I think it shows actually how in her role as I guess overseeing Britain and overseeing the Commonwealth she's kind of helped to enable that so so Tom are you aware of any books written about Britain's soft power during the Queen's reign and her the transformation of Britain's image from a sort of Victorian imperialist industrial powerhouse to a nation of entertainers and storytellers. Is there a book on the shelves behind you that may be? Yes.
它们不被接受。而他开辟了那条道路。我认为这实际上展示了她在监督英国和监督英联邦的角色中，是如何帮助促成了这一点的。所以，汤姆，你知道有什么关于女王统治期间英国软实力以及英国形象从一个维多利亚时代的帝国主义工业强国转变为一个由艺人和故事讲述者组成的国家的书籍吗？你身后的书架上有没有这样一本书？是的。
Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island. The Great British Dream Factory is the title. Yes. So, yeah, because I have this thesis that basically what happened from the 1960s onwards is that as Britain lost its empire, it kind of reinvented itself and found, I mean, Dean Acheson, the American Secretary of State, famously, said this much-quoted line about Great Britain has lost an empire
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的《快乐岛》。书名是《伟大的英国梦想工厂》。是的。所以，是的，因为我有这样一个论点，即基本上从20世纪60年代开始发生的事情是，随着英国失去其帝国，它在某种程度上重塑了自己并找到了——我的意思是，美国国务卿迪安·艾奇逊有一句著名的广为人知的名言：大英帝国已经失去了一个帝国
and not yet found a role. But I think in some ways, everything that you're saying, Francis, about creativity, which nobody ever said about Britain before the 1960s. So everybody said the nation of shopkeepers or pith-helmeted kind of empire builders and all this sort of stuff even though actually we were very creative even then but our our self-image as the as the as a people who create these kinds of image you know avant-garde art pushing the boundaries of music um you know in fiction and poetry and all in film are on the stage.
却没有找到一个角色。但我认为在某些方面，弗朗西斯你所说的关于创造力的所有事情，在20世纪60年代之前没有人这样评价过英国。所以每个人都说这个国家是小店主或者是戴着遮阳帽的帝国建设者之类的话，尽管实际上即使在那个时候我们也极具创造力，但我们对自己的自我形象——作为一个创造这种形象的民族，你知道的，前卫艺术突破音乐的界限，你知道的，在小说、诗歌、电影和舞台上——
That's where Atana lies. And that's obviously Danny Boyle celebrated all of that, didn't he? The 2012 Olympics. And that is in Sex Pistols, of course. So it all goes around. Exactly. Sex Pistols have become part of the heritage industry. Exactly.
这才是我们的天赋所在。丹尼·博伊尔显然庆祝了这一切，不是吗？2012年奥运会。当然还有性手枪乐队。所以这一切都转了一圈。没错。性手枪乐队已经成为了遗产产业的一部分。没错。
They have become part. Well, the Sex Pistols are part of the heritage industry now. And that's something that is absolutely emblematic, I think, of her reign. When people in the 25th century talk about the reign of Elizabeth II, they'll undoubtedly use a clip of the Beatles to illustrate it, won't they? I mean, there'll be a clip of Union Jacks coming down in West Africa or something. And then they'll cut to somebody with a new washing machine and then the Beatles. And they'll say this was late 20th century Britain. And I think that's actually, that self-image of ourselves as kind of hilariously witty and creative people
他们已经成为了……好吧，性手枪乐队现在是遗产产业的一部分。我认为这绝对是她统治时期的一个象征。当25世纪的人们谈论伊丽莎白二世的统治时，他们无疑会使用披头士乐队的一个片段来阐述，不是吗？我的意思是，会有一个在西非降下英国国歌旗帜或类似事物的片段。然后他们会切换到一个拿着新洗衣机的普通人，然后是披头士乐队。他们会说这是20世纪后期的英国。我认为实际上，我们认为自己是一群滑稽幽默且富有创造力的人的这种自我形象，
is not something that any previous generation of Britons would have said about themselves. And cool Britannia, let's not forget the 90s. Yeah. Actually, David Bowie is one of the few British rock giants who wasn't, as far as i know assimilated into the you know he wasn't dragged into the kind of the tractor beam of queen jubilee's performances and things he never did that did he i don't think it's hard to imagine isn't it i mean
并不是任何先前几代英国人会对他们自己说的话。还有酷不列颠，让我们不要忘记90年代。是的。事实上，大卫·鲍伊是少数几个没有——据我所知——被同化到英国摇滚巨星行列中的人，你知道的，他没有被拉进女王禧年表演之类的引力场中，他从来没有那样做过，不是吗？我不认为。这很难想象，不是吗？我的意思是
so when he he wore union jack coats and things that was that was like kind of he was a mod he was yeah there was a strong streak of irony in it well i tell you what so we we had the great privilege of selling his collection a few years ago and when it first got announced that david bowie was selling his collection everyone thought that his collection would be you know international sort of poppy andy warhol's gerhard richter's what other pop stars collect. What was so cool about Bowie, and I think again this sort of speaks to what we're talking about, your title, The Dream Factory, is that he was collecting in the 90s and he didn't buy people like Warhol and Richter.
所以当他穿着印有英国国旗的外套之类的时候，那就像是——他是一个摩斯族，他，是的，里面有很强的讽刺意味。好吧，我告诉你，我们几年前有幸出售了他的收藏品，当大卫·鲍伊要出售他的收藏品的消息刚宣布时，每个人都认为他的收藏品会是，你知道的，国际波普艺术，安迪·沃霍尔的，格哈德·里希特的，其他流行歌星会收集的东西。关于鲍伊最酷的事情是——我认为这再次契合了我们正在谈论的内容，你的书名《梦想工厂》——他在90年代收藏，他没有买安迪·沃霍尔和里希特那样的人的作品。
He bought what at the time would have been really quite random British artists, but he bought them because they'd walked the same paths as he. They meant something to him. They came from the same landscape as him. And so they resonated with him. And I think that's another essence of our creativity that you can't get away from as well, is that maybe it's because under Queen Elizabeth of the Rain, you know, she's overseen a Britain that inspires people like that.
他买的在当时可以说是相当随机的英国艺术家作品，但他买它们是因为他们走过与他相同的道路。它们对他有意义。他们和他来自相同的风景。所以它们与他产生了共鸣。我认为这也是我们创造力的另一个本质，你是无法摆脱的，也许是因为在超女王伊丽莎白的统治下，你知道的，她监督了一个能够激励这样的人的英国。
And I think that was the most amazing thing about his collecting and I suppose that's why I wanted to talk about this picture just because it sort of shines a light on a slightly unknown part of him um he you know he never did what anyone expected and what was so great about his art was that it was unexpectedly British but isn't there a way isn't there a I mean I don't know what you'd think about this, that in a way, it's actually... I mean, David Bowie's kind of classic example in a sense that he was constantly reinventing himself. I mean, that's what he's famous for. He's constantly reinventing himself. But there is a sense in which he kind of slightly ran out of steam.
我认为这是他收藏中最了不起的事情，我想这也是我想谈论这幅画的原因，只是因为它照亮了他一个稍微鲜为人知的一面，嗯，他，你知道的，他从不做任何符合任何人预期的事，他的艺术如此伟大之处在于它是出人意料的英国式的。但是，难道没有一种方式——难道没有一个——我的意思是，我不知道你们对此怎么看，某种程度上，它实际上是……我的意思是，大卫·鲍伊在某种程度上是一个典型的例子，他不断地重塑自己。我的意思是，这就是他闻名的原因。他不断地重塑自己。但某种程度上，他有点后劲不足了。
And certainly musically and as an icon, he began to seem a bit tired. He probably was tired after. Couldn't you say that about the cycle of creativity, I suppose, paradigmatically began in the 60s? There's quite a strain of self-parody in British popular culture at the moment. It's endlessly kind of reheating half-eaten meals in the microwave. But I think that's been the case actually since the 60s, Tom. I mean, you could argue people were probably, half-eaten meals in the microwave. But I think that's been the case actually since the 60s, Tom.
当然，在音乐上作为一个偶像，他开始显得有些疲惫。他在经历之后可能真的很累了。难道你不能说，创意循环——我想它范式化地始于60年代——也是如此吗？目前英国流行文化中存在着相当多的自我讽刺。它无休止地在微波炉里加热半生不熟的剩饭。但汤姆，我认为实际上从60年代起就是这样了。我的意思是，你可以说人们可能在——微波炉里加热半生不熟的剩饭。但汤姆，我认为实际上从60年代起就是这样了，
I mean, you could argue people were probably, I mean, I think people were saying that about, you know, Sgt. Pepper or something, that it was cannibalising Victorian music all. It was, you know, it was back when- Yeah, but they were the first to do it. Yeah, but I mean- Everyone else is just continuing to do it. I mean, I think you can definitely argue that the culture produced and during the, certainly the latter part of the reign of Elizabeth II has been,
我的意思是，你可以说人们可能在——我的意思是，我认为人们对《佩珀中士》或类似的东西说过类似的话，说它是在蚕食维多利亚时代的音乐大厅。它，你知道的，那是以前——是的，但他们是第一个这么做的。是的，但我的意思是——其他人只是在继续这样做。我的意思是，你绝对可以争辩说，在伊丽莎白二世统治的后期所产生的文化，
has been very, you know, obsessed often with our own history, with looking backwards, with constantly reinter, I mean, we, I mean, how often have we talked about this on our podcast about the sort of introverted, the constant sort of, oh, the fixation on our, on our on the on the our own history and particularly the victorian period um again and again and in a way it's there's some elements of being trapped in a cycle that you can't quite escape i guess that's that's britain isn't it that's part of our eccentric legacy because i mean in a way we're lucky we've got all this history however turbulent it was to reference back maybe you know that's why around the world that brown britain they like the sort of edgy side of it but then they like that
通常非常，你知道的，痴迷于我们自己的历史，痴迷于回顾过去，不断地重新诠释——我的意思是，我们，我的意思是，我们在播客中谈论过多少次这种内向、这种不断的痴迷——哦，对我们的历史尤其是维多利亚时代的执念，一次又一次。在某种程度上，这其中包含了一些被困在无法完全逃脱的循环中的元素，我想这就是英国，对吧？那是我们古怪遗产的一部分，因为我的意思是，在某种程度上我们很幸运，我们拥有所有这些历史，无论它曾经多么动荡，可以作为参考，也许，你知道的，这就是为什么世界各地的人们喜欢英国——他们喜欢它边缘化的一面，但随后他们又喜欢它与一种遗产并置。我的意思是，某种程度上，它存在于女王陛下的精彩演绎中——我们以它开场——但在60年代有一种感觉，这又是《佩珀中士》以及60年代的大多数流行文化发挥作用的地方，这种边缘感在于采取一种死板的帝国意象，并把它变得，你知道的，时髦，把它变成某种令人愉快的东西——英国国旗迷你裙、马甲之类的那种——那才是重点。但现在，我的意思是，不，你知道的，当杰瑞·哈利韦尔这样做时，谁在乎呢？我的意思是，每个人都这么做过了。现在还有什么可做的？我的意思是，现在做这件事太显而易见了。
it's placed next to a sort of like a heritage i mean in a sense though it's there in her majesty the brilliant rendition of which we we opened this with but there was a sense in the 60s and this again is where sergeant pepper comes in and so much of the popular culture of the 60s that the edginess lay in taking a stayed imperial imagery and kind of making it you know groovy making it something kind of enjoyable union jack mini skirts and waistcoats and things like that that was the point but now i mean no you know when when jerry hallowell did it who cared? I mean, everyone had done that. And now what is there to do? I mean, it's such an obvious thing to do now.
你知道的，甚至连性手枪乐队的事也是。我的意思是，那是多久以前的事了？几十年前了。我能说一件我刚刚意识到 A 事吗？我还没有提到关于我们展览的一个相当核心的事情，它再次呼应了遗产以及人们对君主制的期望，那就是我们借了所有这些王冠来展示。还有王冠。汤姆喜欢王冠，弗朗西斯。
You know, even the Sex Pistols thing. I mean, that was how long ago? I mean, decades ago. Can I say something that I just realised? I haven't mentioned something quite key about our exhibition that sort of speaks again to the heritage and what people expect from monarchy is that we've borrowed all these tiaras to show. And tiaras. Tom loves a tiara, Francis.
我的确喜欢王冠。我就知道。所以这是你的最后一件展品？这是我们最后一件官方展品。我想顺便提一下，我们借来了黛安娜1981年结婚时戴的王冠，多米尼克，你很喜欢她，你很喜欢婚礼，不是吗？你喜欢皇室婚礼。我们实际上谈论过这个，我们谈论过皇室婚礼。我们谈过。我当时有没有说过我有多么讨厌婚礼？你说了。是的，你说了。以我扮演的咿呀（悲观者）身份。
I do love a tiara. I thought so. So this is your last item? This is our last official item. And I thought just to throw it out there we've borrowed diana's tiara from her wedding in 1981 dominic you you love her you you love a wedding don't you you love a royal wedding we actually talked about that we talked about the royal wedding we did did i say then how much i disliked weddings generally? You did. Yes, you did. In my capacity as Eeyore.
是的，所以这是戴安娜王妃的王冠。显然是在1981年佩戴的。这似乎是英国战后命运最低谷的绝对谷底，81年的夏天，因为布里克斯顿和托克斯思刚刚发生了暴动。有300万失业人口。是的，贝尔法斯特的绝食抗议。撒切尔夫人是有记录以来最不受欢迎的首相，诸如此类。
Yeah, so this is Princess Diana's tiara. So obviously worn in 1981. The absolute sort of nadir of what seemed like the nadir of Britain's post-war fortunes, the summer of 81, because there'd just been the riots in Brixton and Toxteth. Had 3 million unemployed. Yeah, the hunger strikes in Belfast. Mrs Thatcher was the least popular prime minister since records began and all that sort of thing.
然后是查尔斯和黛安娜的婚礼。罗伯特·伦西曾说过关于这会不会是一个童话故事的话？显然，我们都知道它不是。所以总是有那样一个阴影，不是吗？因此，当你讲述女王和她的统治的故事时，我的意思是，我不惊讶你拥有一个戴安娜王妃的文物，但总是有这样一个问题，那就是有一种——
And then the wedding of Charles and Diana. Robert Runcie famously says these things about, is it going to be a fairy tale? Obviously, we all know that it wasn't. So there is always that shadow, isn't there? So when you tell the story of the queen and her reign, I mean, I'm not surprised you have a Princess Diana artefact, but there is always this issue that there is the sort of,
总是有，你知道的，衣橱里藏着不可告人的秘密，不是吗？但我们是否认为，因为这——我想它让皇室变成了一个真正的家庭，是的，在某种程度上，你知道的，一方面我们一直在谈论他们在很多形象中必须被高高供奉在基座上，但另一方面，他们是真正的人，生活在一个真正的家庭里，尽管有着我们其他人所没有的不同环境和城堡。实际上，就王冠而言，我的意思是，因为显然只有——目前，只有贵族女性和皇室女性才会佩戴它们。
there are always, you know, there are sort of skeletons rattling in the closet, aren't there? But do we think that that makes because it i suppose it makes the royal family a real family yeah in a way you know at the one hand we've been talking about how in a lot of the imagery they've got to be set on pedestal but then on the other hand they are real people in a real family albeit with different circumstances and castles that the rest of us have actually Actually, in terms of the tiaras, I mean, because obviously there's only, at the moment, it was only noble women and royal women that wore them.
不过它们本身就是很了不起的物品，因为除了佩戴它们并有机会拥有它们的人之外，其他人真的只能从相当远的距离看到它们。但当你近距离看到它们时——我们希望卡门、多米尼克，你们会来看一看。我很乐意去，我很乐意去看看——它们是工艺精美的物品，有太多的细节从远处看都丢失了。所以这是谁的王冠？我的意思是，我知道它是戴安娜王妃戴过的，但它是斯宾塞王冠还是皇室王冠？我们从绝大多数王冠依然属于的那些家族那里借来了所有这些东西。所以这是一顶斯宾塞王冠，是吗？
They're sort of amazing objects in their own right, though, because you only really, apart from the person who wears them and gets to hold them, everyone else sees them from quite a distance. But when you do see them up close, and we hope, Carmen, Dominic, you'll come and see them. i'd love to come on i'd love to come on that they are beautifully crafted objects there's so much detail that is sort of lost from a distance so whose tiara is it i mean i know it's diana warwick but is it a spencer tiara or a royal tiara we've we've borrowed all these things from the families to which most of them all still belong. So this is a Spencer tiara, is it?
这是一顶斯宾塞王冠。这些王冠的另一个神奇之处在于，通常它们无论在哪里都被锁在保险箱里，现在它们出来透透气，供大家观赏，也供你和多米尼克试戴。尽管有趣的是，如果你想的话——
This is a Spencer tiara. And what's also amazing about these tiaras is normally they're locked away in safes wherever they are, and they're coming out for a little outing for everyone to see and for you and Dominic to try on. Although it's funny that if you think,
如果你闭上眼睛想象女王的形象，你可能会想到她戴着王冠、冠冕或者帽子——戴着帽子，是的，我现在要想想，是的，她戴着帽子，她戴着帽子。我试过，她还有那个伟大的形象，在最近的议会开幕式上，查尔斯王子旁边放着一顶冠冕，字面意思上的冠冕，代表着——好吧，冠冕有它自己的专车运送到——但许多人，我注意到，我能想象现在住在你家附近的那种人，汤姆，他们在社交媒体上对此冷嘲热讽——不，布里克斯顿的人，我们热爱女王，你知道吗？查尔斯王子过去非常受欢迎，他去布里克斯顿的时候被人群围堵，是的，他
if you close your eyes and think of an image of the Queen, you probably think of her with either a crown, aara or a hat on a hat um yeah i'm now gonna think about yeah she's wearing a hat she's wearing a hat i've tried it and she there was the great image at the recent um opening of parliament with prince charles next to a crown literally crown representing well the crown got its own got its own vehicle taking it to the but and a lot of people i noticed sort of people who i imagine who live now in your neck of the woods tom were being sniffy about this on social no people in brixton we love we love the queen do you prince charles is when he was very popular he was mobbed when he goes to brixton yeah he
在布里克斯顿建立了各种各样的东西。骑术学校之类的事物。是的。真不错。我非常支持查尔斯王子。而且他当然拥有椭圆球场。我不得不说。好吧，我们将在文明的战场上相见——好吧，事实上，事实是，如果真的出现继承危机，
set he set up um all kinds of stuff in Brixton. Riding stables and things. Yeah. Good for him. I'm very much team Prince Charles. And he owns the Oval, of course. I have to say. Well, we shall meet on the civil battlefields of... Well, actually, the truth of the matter is if it does come to a succession crisis,
我无疑会支持安妮公主。我认为她很有钢铁般的意志。她做不出查尔斯王子那样的好饼干。我认为她没有爱德华王子那样好的文学判断力。但我认为她会带着一大群苏格兰人南下，不是吗？她会的，是的，而且他们都会很擅长橄榄球。是的。
I would undoubtedly back Princess Anne. I think she has the steel. She doesn't make as good biscuits as Prince Charles's. I don't think she has as good literary judgment as Prince Edward. But I think she would come south, wouldn't she, with a massive horde of Scots. She would, yes, and they'd all be very good at rugby. Yeah.
我的意思是，他们都会穿着格子呢。她会拥有最好的骑兵，不是吗？她会拥有最好的骑兵。她是。我只是在想阔剑。他们会载歌载舞。会吗？我想他们会……她会拥有最好的骑兵，不是吗？她会拥有最好的骑兵。她是。我只是在想阔剑。他们会载歌载舞。会吗？我想他们会把别人的头砍下来。
I mean, they'd all be clad in tartan. She'd have the best cavalry, wouldn't she? She'd have the best cavalry. She is. I'm just thinking of claymores. And they'd all kind of dance. Would they? I think they'd be be... She'd have the best cavalry, wouldn't she? She'd have the best cavalry. She is. I'm just thinking of claymores. And they'd all kind of dance. Would they? I think they'd be cleaving people's heads off.
不，不，他们的马会跳舞。哦，是的。因为那是她的技能，不是吗？那是她的超能力吗？这是她的奥运技能。对。是的。好吧。
No, no, their horses would dance. Oh, yeah. Because that's her skill, isn't it? Is that her superpower? It's her Olympic skill. Right. Yes. Okay.
关于黛安娜的事，只有最后一件事。是的。因为她的去世众所周知为女王制造了巨大的危机。她觉得也许自己正在失去广大英国公众的喜爱。而基本上她——结果并非如此。我不知道有多少人想要回共和国——20％？是类似这样的数字吗？实际上一直相当稳定。它确实增长了一点，但我认为共和情绪竟然如此薄弱，这真是引人注目，考虑到，你知道的，如果你在20世纪60年代或70年代询问人们，我想他们可能会预料到它会比现在增长得更多。
Just one last thing on the Diana thing. Yeah. Because her death famously created the great crisis for the Queen. And she felt that perhaps she was losing the affection of the great British public. And basically she she has that turned out not to be the case. And I don't know what proportion of people want to republic back 20 percent. Is it something like that? It's been pretty static, actually. It has grown a little bit, but it's remarkable how weak Republican sentiment is, I would say, given, you know, if you were asking people in the 1960s or 1970s, I think they might expect it to grow more than it has.
但是，我的意思是，有一个问题，那就是当她去世时，你认为人们会觉得她为君主制的未来保驾护航了吗？对查尔斯安全，对威廉安全，还是她的统治会显得像某种……你知道的，它持续了那么久，然后当她离去时，一切都随之而去了？你觉得呢，多米尼克？因为你把她比作——叫什么名字来着？奥匈帝国的弗朗茨·约瑟夫，是的，约瑟夫。我是他的超级粉丝，嗯……但他统治了多年又多年，然后他确实——但这——那最终崩溃其实是因为第一次世界大战，我会这么说，嗯……
But, I mean, a question, which is when she dies, do you think she will be seen to have made the future safe for monarchy? So safe for Charlesles safe for william or will she will her reign seem like something that um you know it lasted so long and then when she went everything went what do you think dominic because you compared her to uh what's his name the austrian hungarian franz joseph yeah joseph i'm a big fan of him um uh but he reigned for years and years and years and then he did but he that his that that only fell apart really because of the first world war i would say and um i think yeah i i think she'll she'll hand over the the baton with the institution in actually pretty good shape considering how it could have been you You know, if you think about the pressures
我认为，是的，考虑到可能的情况，我认为她会在君主制机构状况相当不错的情况下交出接力棒。你知道的，如果你想想20世纪末的压力、顺从的消亡、民粹主义的崛起、媒体无拘无束的关注。我的意思是，很难想象有谁能像她那样应对得如此出色。好吧，所以那是，你知道的，查尔斯将如何，将如何——
of the late 20th century, the death of deference, the rise of populism, the sort of unbridled attention of the media. I mean, it's hard to imagine anybody coping as well as she coped. Right. So that's, you know, how will Charles, how will...
好吧，当然，到那时我们将生活在一个不同的世界里。实际上，我会说，我的意思是，他们将如何应对？我的意思是，他们做得越少越好，或者他们养精蓄锐，等待他们忠诚的心腹在意外中支持他们——我不认为爱德华王子会成为国王，汤姆，我们可以做梦，对吧？弗朗西斯，你认为爱德华王子会成为国王吗？最后一个问题，这更多是关于为汤姆还是为多米尼克投票？不，我只是在问你，珍妮，你认为爱德华王子：A，有争夺王冠的杀手本能；B，你认为他作为专制的绝对君主，能把国家治理得很好吗？
Well, of course, we'll be living in a different world then. And actually, I would say, I mean, how will they cope? I mean, way the less they do the better or they bide their time and wait for their loyal henchmen to right back them in an unexpected i don't think prince edward's ever going to be king tom we can dream right francis do you think prince edward would be king final question is this more about a vote, though, for Tom or Dominic? No, I'm just asking you, Jenny, do you think Prince Edward, A, has the killer instinct to make a bid for the crown, and B, do you think he'd make a good fist of ruling the country
我不认为他会成为国王。好吧，那就这样吧。好吧，这是一个沉重而结束的话题。但是，你知道，我们并不害怕正视严酷的真相并提出重大问题。所以让我们稍微谈谈你们的展览，因为我相信你们的展览是——你说过它是对公众免费的。
as a despotic, absolute monarch? I don't think he's going to get to be king. Okay, well, there you go. Okay, that's a tough note on which to end. But, you know, we're not afraid to look at the grim truth and ask the big questions. So let's just talk a little bit about your exhibition because I believe your exhibition is – you said it was free to the public.
所以它在5月28日开幕。你们有——我没记错的话，乔安娜·拉姆利将是你们的——乔安娜·拉姆利是演讲者之一。所有的讲座都是免费的，人们只需要预订即可，所以只需访问sotheby's.com前斜杠jubilee，人们就可以预订座位。不过七位女王和我们50顶王冠的展览是完全免费的，你不需要为此预订，你可以随时进来，我们从9点开放到4点半。我们正在做一个周末活动——那是我们有
So it opens on the 28th of May. And you've got – am I right in thinking Joanna Lumley is going to be your – Joanna Lumley is one of the speakers. And all the talks are free you just people do need to book those so just go to sotheby's.com forward slash jubilee and people can book their places the exhibitions though of the seven queens and our 50 tiaras are totally free you don't have to book for that you can just come in at any time we're open from 9 to 4 30 we're doing a's Weekend so that's when we've got
“熊之战”的时候。熊之战，我必须说，“熊之战”是吸引我来的原因，而不是那些王冠，“熊之战”听起来太棒了。
the Battle of the Bears the Battle of the Bears I have to say the Battle of the Bears is what blew me in rather than the tiaras the Battle of the Bears sounds amazing
不过我有50顶王冠。好吧，“熊之战”，你为什么不把这两者结合起来，举办一场戴着王冠的“熊之战”呢？好吧，他们可以为王冠而战。是的。
I had 50 tiaras though well the Battle of the Bears why don't you combine the two and have the Battle of the Bears with them wearing the tiaras well they could fight over the tiaras yeah
或者用王冠作战。我认为50顶到50顶王冠——我的意思是，那是一个令人印象深刻的王冠数量。王冠的集体称呼是什么？到底是什么？一闪耀的王冠，一璀璨的王冠。告诉我，你有一种——你错失了你的职业，王冠爱好者。
or fight with tiaras I think 50 to 50 tiaras I mean that's that's an impressive number of tiaras what's a collective number of tiaras what's a collective exactly a glitter a dazzle a dazzle of tiaras tell me you've got such a sort of you missed your vocation tiara enthusiast
所以还有什么别的——除了——我们在这个节目上有六个项目了，还有什么突出的项目是你们拥有的吗？所以我确实有一个项目，它有点联系到英联邦，回到我们刚才谈论的话题。它有点抽象。所以它是巴巴拉·赫普沃斯的一件雕塑。它是从一整块木头中雕刻出来的。它又高又呈椭圆形。它上面有非常优雅的洞，我想可以这么说。
and so what other what apart so we've we've had six items on on this what what other that stand out items that you've got so i do have item, which it kind of links to Commonwealth, going back to what we were talking about. It's a bit abstract. So it's a sculpture by Barbara Hepworth. And it's carved out of a single piece of wood. It's tall and oval. And it has these really elegant sort of holes in it, I guess.
那些洞被涂成了白色。它是在1945年雕刻的。所以就在伊丽莎白登基之前。但它非常特别，因为它是独一无二的，而她的许多作品都被做成了青铜材质。我想提到它是因为我们讨论了很多关于英联邦的内容，但我当时没有一件物品来代表英联邦。
And those holes are painted white. And it was carved in 1945. So just pre-Elizabeth's coming to the throne. But it's really special because it's unique where a lot of her work was made into bronze. And I guess I wanted to mention it because we talked quite a lot about Commonwealth, but I didn't have an object at the time to represent Commonwealth.
但我认为这个雕塑有点符合这一点，因为战后，英国文化协会对我们的艺术家们来说太棒了，他们把艺术家们送到了英联邦。他们认为这是一种建立文化伙伴关系并将我们的艺术家带给更广泛公众的方式。所以英国文化协会派出了像赫普沃斯和摩尔这样的人环游世界，几乎就像他们的代言人一样，作为女王的代言人，展示我们的创造力以及我们在国内制作的东西，如果你愿意的话。我认为这个雕塑在某种程度上代表了这一点。这再次触及了软实力的观点，我想是的，对吧？
But I think this sculpture sort of does because post-war, the British Council were amazing for our artists at getting them out to the Commonwealth. They sort of saw it as a way of having cultural partnerships and of getting our artists out to a wider public. So the British Council sent people like Hepworth and more around the world, almost as their spokespeople, as the Queen's spokespeople, to show how creative we were and what we were making at home, if you like. And I think this sculpture kind of represents that. Does that point about soft power again, I guess, isn't it?
是的。而且赫普沃斯，我的意思是，她相当激进。在战前、二战前时期，实际上很少有重要的女性艺术家。幸运的是现在更多了。但是，你知道，她就像女王本人一样，因为她是一个罕见的存在，A，作为一个女性艺术家，
Yeah. And also Hepworth, I mean, she's quite radical. There's very few major female artists, actually, in the pre-war, pre-Second World War period. There's luckily more now. But, you know, she was like the queen herself in that she was a rare thing, A, to be a female artist,
但作为一个女性雕塑家，那真是超级罕见。她一路上生了好多孩子，就像女王有四个孩子一样令人惊叹——我的意思是，虽然没有维多利亚女王那么多，但你永远不会——这本身就是一个相当了不起的壮举，尽管她在怀孕期间和不断旅行中完成了所有这些盛大庆典，不是吗？她不断地旅行？我的意思是，本质上回到英联邦的起源，我的意思是，基本上每当有……你知道的，政治危机或类似的事情时，政府就会把她派出去，她就会去印度或加纳之类的地方一去就是几个月，因为你碰巧坐船出行，然后通常正如我所说，他们也会把艺术家的作品送出去，
but to be a female sculptor, that was super rare. She had loads of kids amongst the way just like it's pretty amazing the queen's four kids i mean not as many as victoria but you never that that's quite a feat in itself even though she did all this pageantry pregnant and constantly traveling wasn't she constantly traveling i mean essentially going back to the origins of the commonwealth i mean basically whenever there was um you know a political crisis or something the government would send her out and and she'd be off to india or ghana or something for months at a time because you happen to go by ship and then often as i said they'd send artists works out too
我想以此作为……向更广泛的受众传达英国信息的某种方式。但我有一个由大约20件艺术品组成的展览，无论是在香港、内罗毕还是其他什么地方，都可以向人们讲述这个故事。在某种程度上，我的意思是，她不可能一直访问所有这些地方，但艺术品可以。所以这个展览，你需要去sotheby.com斜杠jubilee。今天播客的重大爆料再次是——弗朗西斯·克里斯蒂说她认为爱德华王子不会成为国王。而在发生继承危机的情况下，你不能指望她会支持汤姆·霍兰德最喜欢的候选人。所以在这样一个重磅消息下，
as a way i suppose of um telling the message of britain to that wider audience but i have an exhibition of i don't know 20 objects that could tell the story to people wherever it was in Hong Kong or yeah Nairobi or wherever it be in a way I mean she couldn't visit all those places all the time but the art objects could so the exhibition you need to go to sotheby's.com uh slash jubilee uh the big revelation of today's podcast again is uh Frances Christie saying that she doesn't think Prince Edward will be king. And in the event of the succession crisis, you cannot expect her to be backing Tom Holland's favourite candidate. So on that bombshell,
一定要去苏富比的展览。享受禧年。再次感谢弗朗西斯，这是一次非常有趣的对话。我们下次在《历史其余部分》节目中再见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。
do go to the Sotheby's exhibition. Enjoy the Jubilee. And thank you again, Frances, for a really fun conversation. And we'll see you all next time on The Rest is History. Goodbye. Bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。